[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
uni'sons pato volet donnant entre la zac
de melon et la vallée de de l'yvette
sont situées sur un site classé et ce
site du coup est régi par l'état
directement et par la commission des
sites qui détermine si le tracé si le
projet si les matériaux sont adéquates
par rapport à l'environnement du site
les travaux ont des melons des marées
ont démarré en ce début dans ce début
septembre ils vont durer six mois pour
la première liaison puis six mois début
2022 sur la deuxième liaison qui donne
davantage sur bures-sur-yvette la
première donnant sur aux recettes
l'objectif de ces liaisons est avant
tout de créer un lien entre la zac de
moulon et le plateau saclay et la vallée
avec l'université paris saclay l'autre
objectif c'est de converger les flux
piétons sur ces deux liaisons et éviter
des cheminements sauvage pour permettre
le reboisement du coton ainsi les
chercheurs les habitants et les
enseignants de l'univers skipper ses
clés de la vallée du plateau pourront
commencer à utiliser ses liaisons à
partir de l'été 2001
ces deux liaisons sont donc manière
d'anticiper aussi les développements du
plateau puisqu'elles vont relier dès à
présent l'université et les grandes
écoles mais aussi les quartiers
d'habitation qui viennent d'être livrés
puis à terme le métro et tout le
développement de lettres du quartier ces
liaisons s'inscrivent dans un grand
système effectivement de sites classés
en même temps ou si toute la vallée de
chevreuse et tout un système de pare
aussi urbain c'est à la fois un milieu
naturel
urbain d'où la difficulté de réunir à
ces deux éléments à la fois de conforter
des usages qui sont celles d'une
métropole et en même temps les milieux
naturels donc c'est tout l'enjeu
tivement de ce projet on a mis en place
un vocabulaire extrêmement simple qui
reprend le vocabulaire des liaisons qui
existe déjà sur polytechnique ou sur la
vallée de chevreuse avec un vocabulaire
de grands en marche mais donc là qui
sont pas en grès qui sont des blocs
effectivement préfabriqués en béton mais
qui sont posées comme ont posé autrefois
les boeufs gras est sur du sable et puis
de grand pavé degré de récupération dont
qui sont directement issues finalement
des coteaux qui était exploité jusqu'à
la fin du 19ème début du xxème sur ces
liaisons
[Musique]